the skills und herzlich willkommen zu
diesem kleinen info video keine sorge es
kommt heute noch ein richtiges video das
kommt wahrscheinlich nachher und so
14.30 glaciers erstmal info video in
diesem video werde ich bekanntgeben wer
das abo special gewonnen hat es war mehr
als fünf leute zu meiner ja nicht meiner
schande gestehen aber es war auf jeden
fall mehr als 5 1 jahr die bewerbungen
versucht gefallen haben und ich auch ein
größeres kontingent bekommen habe es
fünf plätze und deswegen ich gehe jetzt
mal den namen bescheid ich hatte
ursprünglich schon alle leute bei
youtube ein eingeschriebener youtube ist
über die größte scheiß ich krieg selbst
keine nachrichten angezeigt
die mir gesendet werden ich weiß nicht
was da los ist deswegen wenn ihr zu den
leuten gehört die ich jetzt gleich
vorleser oder wenn er die leute kennt
dann schickt mir also die gewinner die
jetzt vorgelesen werden schicken an abo
special stuttgart blog.de eine e mail
ganz wichtig und in der e-mail nennt dem
ihr euren namen und ich antworte euch
dann sagt auch die adresse des events
also special stuttgart auto.de die e
mail ist auch nochmal unten in der
beschreibung unbedingt oder namen
schicken sonst könnt ihr nicht dahin
und dann war der ganze käse sonst also
alle gewinner die jetzt gleich
vorgelesen werden den vor und nachnamen
per mail
anna boos bei stuttgart outlook punkt de
schicken
das sind ganz schöner aufwand so ein
ding zu koordinieren aber gut lass mich
kurz dass hierüber ziehen ja ich hab mir
übrigens mögen schlechter da habt ihr
recht das ich bislang wurde gestern hat
verballert ok ich das jetzt einfach mal
die gewinner vor sei bereit so der erste
ist msi flashmob also das sind youtube
kanal namen fleischmann bei den namen
schicken linken beschreibung chris and
gaming die hat mir auch schon den namen
geschickt ein danny mitchell prx hd
jonas engel lexus lifestyle von der abi
aber auch schon den namen ich da an timo
jann dickinger essen sie das daisy lowe
waffel boxer 23 96 das waren die namen
ein ganz liebes dankeschön auch noch
anstiege bertina kubus und wollpullis
jetzt auch noch richtig richtig richtig
gute bewerbung ein geschickt aber die
konnte ich dann leider nicht mehr
aufnehmen
also das hat mich echt ein bisschen
abgefragt also ich meine das ist
wirklich so ich saß da an hat wirklich
viele viele coole bewerbungen und fans
extrem dankeschön handy extrem scheiße
dass ich dann einige ablehnen musste
logitech schnauze der echte gespinst es
ist mord der mir whatsapp nachrichten
schickt ja also wie gesagt alle dickert
vorgelesen wurden
eine e mail mit eurem namen an die
adresse in der beschreibung schicken ist
ganz wichtig dankeschön und dann viel
spaß mit dem heutigen video was dann
gleich kommt okay so macht's gut